alors je vais commencer par une histoire
pour les enfants mais aussi pour les
adultes
donc c'est le vol du colibri d'après une
légende amérindienne écouter l'histoire
de la grande forêt s'est embrasée
un terrible feu faisait rage la terreur
s'était emparée de tous les animaux qui
s'enfuyaient comme ils le pouvaient
l'orignal le lièvre l'ours l'écureuil
tous couret et au dessus d'eux les
oiseaux virevoltant en panique
ils se sont tous hamas à l'orée de la
forêt pour attendre la suite des choses
tous sauf un seul kerry qui le petit
colibri était resté dans la forêt quand
le feu s'est approché de lui et s'est
envolé immédiatement vers le ruisseau
pour fuser une goutte d'eau avec son
minuscule beck qui font ça ensuite sur
le feu et largue à la goutte puis il
retourne en ruisseaux et rapportant une
autre goutte pour la larguer sur le feu
comme ça aller-retour aller-retour
aller-retour les autres animaux
regardait ce tout petit oiseau combattre
l'énorme feux de forêt et lui crier
arrête arrête c'est trop dangereux doit
périr
qu'est-ce que je peux faire brailler le
lièvre c'est bien trop chaud il ya bien
trop de boucane hurler le loup mais
elles vont bull est une île l ue boules
de hibou pourtant le petit colibri
persister aller-retour aller-retour sans
relâche du ruisseau au feu ils arguaient
ces gouttelettes sur le brasier géant à
un moment donné le gros ours dit à kerry
qui me tue bien dit inspiré la du haut
des airs le petit colis berregard à tous
les animaux entassés dans le même coin
il leur dit je fais ce que je peux
alors cette histoire lol du vol du
colibri a été à l'origine d'une autre
histoire qui est celle du vol du colibri
coopérative de solidarité
mais plus loin que ça pour moi je dois
commencer en fait presque à mon enfance
où depuis toujours j'ai voulu être avec
les enfants de moi même la deuxième
d'une famille de sept enfants
donc j'avais à m'occuper des strates
soirée gmail
un peu plus tard j'ai travaillé dans des
camps de vacances pour finalement
commencé à travailler dans des guerres
de l'hiver l'âge de 21 ans
l'amour des enfants c'était mon
principal moteur mais par la suite est
en fait pas très longtemps après
idéaliste come to hell est à cet âge là
je me suis dit que si on voulait
vraiment changer le monde pour
idéalement enfin le meilleur il fallait
commencer par les plus petits par les
petits enfants parce que c'est souvent
et c'est certainement cet âge là où le
développement et plus vers ayew les
enfants peuvent le plus se modeler et je
croyait profondément qu'on pouvait
rendre le monde meilleur à partir des
petits-enfants et de l'éducation et du
soutien qu'on leur donne
par la suite bien j'ai travaillé avec
les enfants comme je vous disais et j'ai
aussi vécu j'étais moi même une mère une
grand mère j'ai aussi travaillé à divers
niveaux ou pour partir des syndicates
garderie en trop de chez terra et j'ai
donc côtoyer des adultes et par la suite
j'ai aussi travaillé auprès de parents
entrent au départ enquête en difficulté
et sera emmené à mesure travaille au
développement des enfants c'est bien
s'en occuper quand on est avec eux peu
importe qu'on soit le parent conçoit
l'éducatrice conçoit d'enseignante où
l'enseignant c'est bien s'occuper des
enfants mais c'est aussi bien soutenir
leurs familles leurs parents les
conditions pour moi de travailler au
développement de l'enfant sont devenus
terres l'enfant est lui même le premier
moteur mais tout s'est tu es prêt il
faut que par an soit soutenue et pour ça
ça prend une communauté autour des
parents ils ne peuvent pas être laissés
seuls dans cette mission là dans une
société qui est de plus en plus
individualiste alors c'est devenu en
quelque sorte mon brasier les enfants et
leurs parents et créer une communauté
autour d'eux ou tenté de le faire avec
les gens qui étaient autour de moi et de
à partir de là je passe un peu d'années
et dans le temps on arrive en 2009 on
était quelques personnes de rouyn
noranda qui travaillait dans ce secteur
depuis plusieurs années
on avait le goût d'aller plus loin dans
notre notre fête dans ce qu'ont apporté
à notre communauté et on connaissait
très bien aussi les besoins on savait
qu'à moins en 2009 il manquait en
service de garde à peu près 1000 places
et on savait que c'était pas juste de ce
que les familles avaient besoin qui
manquaient ou aussi des services au
niveau de la conciliation famille et
autres occupations mais aussi que les
parents pouvaient vivre un certain
désarroi parce que souvent les parents
sont seules avec leurs enfants ont peu
d'occasions de rencontrer d'autres
enfants ou même juste de discuter de ce
qu'ils vivent comme parent avec d'autres
gens comme eux et puis on se dit bon ce
besoin là est présent mais il fallait
qu'on valide noted et puis on a fait des
rencontres avec des parents qu'on s'est
rendu compte effectivement c'était très
réel et là c'est une idée je dois vous
dire moi cette époque que j'avais déjà
quand même 55 ans et on a eu une idée
assez folle qui peut apparaître
aujourd'hui comme ordinaire mais on a
décidé d'essayer de partir une garderie
à une époque où il n'y avait pas de
clans de développement du gouvernement
donc ce que ça veut dire c'est pas de
places subventionnées mais aussi pas de
subvention pour partir ça ça veut dire
aussi pas de locaux pour on est en fait
on est on partait de rien n'évoque une
entité juridique non plus qu'on savait
juste qu'il y avait un besoin et on se
disait aussi en collège entre deux nous
disaient les les jeunes sont beaucoup
plus individualiste maintenant y'a pas
d'appétit pour pouvoir partir quelque
chose collectivement mais on la poterie
pour nous décider d'y aller quand même
on sert on s'y retrouve et en 2009 elle
était avec une centaine de parents une
réunion spéciale convoitiez en pleine
période de la construction alors qu'on
sait pas si facile que ça de rejoindre
les gens et on a vu qu'il y avait
vraiment une volonté qui avait des gens
qui étaient prêts à mettre la main à la
pâte et là ça démarre et on a réussi à
trouver quelqu'un propriétaire que voulu
nous louer des locaux que même accepté
de les aménager
à ces frais nous pour nous lilou et peu
plus tard on a des parents qui sont
impliqués sont venus nous aide à trouver
des équipements matériels d'aidé future
éducatrice aussi c'est assez incroyable
tout le travail s'est fait bénévole des
dons ou si je vous dirais qu à rouyn
noranda des compagnies privées des
compagnies des entreprises d'économie
sociale dans le communautaire d'un
secteur public
un paquet de monde se sont inscrits pour
se doter d'une garderie il a fallu aussi
faire les demandes de permis parce que
bien que la garderie soit pour financer
elle devait être régis par les mêmes
règles que ceux qui sont financés en
réalité donc dac ltd locaux le personnel
formé et tout le reste et semble si on y
est arrivé et finalement quelques mois
plus tard en une permis on avait déjà 75
enfants d'inscrits et on ouvrait le vol
du colibri avec une mission élargie
parce qu'il faut jamais perdre de vue
qu'on ne voulait pas seulement offrir un
service de gamme et offrir un ensemble
de choses qui soutiennent des parements
parents pour leur permettre d'être plus
en forme quand leur enfant vivent le
soin puis ainsi pouvoir donner le
meilleur d'eux mêmes ou leurs enfants
est toujours dans la logique ou encore
l'enfant lui-même c'est sa famille qui
est le plus proche et la communauté qui
l'entourent
lorsqu'on dit n'est ce pas je parlais
tantôt d'amérindiens mais les africains
eux disent que ça prend un village pour
un enfant et on y croyait profondément
donc le vol du collier en 2010 où ses
portes accueille déjà beaucoup d'enfants
offre d'autres services et il se
développe sous forme de coopérative
on a choisi de ne pas aller dans le
volet des garderies commerciales même si
c'était la seule voie qui semblait
possible en dehors des centres de la
petite enfance ou ou des garderies
financées ben nous on a dit ok dans la
loi y existe un autre façon de le faire
c'est une garderie commercial mais nous
ne ne vais pas de ce modèle de on a pris
la voie mon à créer quelque chose de
complètement différent qui probablement
était assez unique au québec
donc c'est devenu une coopérative de
soldats alités
pourquoi une coopérative parce qu'on
croyait profondément qu'il fallait que
l'organiste s'occuperait des enfants
donc la communauté qu'on créerait au
tour des enfants soient fortement
démocratiques et les lois du coopératif
nous permettait d'aller très loin dans
les pouvoirs qu'on peut donner à une
assemblée générale demande notamment sur
le projet éducatif sur les orientations
mais aussi sur les tarifs des parents
auraient à payer et on voulait aussi que
les parents et le pouvoir majoritaire
dans notre assemblée
parce qu'on pense qu évidemment comme je
l'aï dit précédemment les parents sont
les premiers responsables leur enfant
doit donc doit pouvoir dire leur mot au
premier chapitre et on a aussi choisi de
faire une coopérative où les employés
seraient membres parce que pour nous les
employés les parents c'est des
partenaires du développement des enfants
et des membres soutient aussi dieu
apporte beaucoup beaucoup à la
coopérative soit parce qu'ils croient
dans sa mission soit parce qu'ils
vendent sur live dont avoir une place
auprès de auprès de nous on a aussi
choisi un statut à but non lucratif
parce qu'on pensait que l'argent qui
serait qui éventuellement resterez dans
les coffres de la coopérative devrait
être réinvesti en autant de gouttes
d'eau pour contribuer aux autres enfants
tu viendrais le coopérative puis aux
autres familles alors ça ça a été
vraiment le premier bout et pas
longtemps à presto un an et demi après
on a dû déménager de locaux on s'est
installés ailleurs
et encore une fois c'est toute la
communauté drouin qui a mis la main à la
pâte en plein hiver entre 2002 11 et
2012 tout la garderie est déménagée dans
ses nouveaux locaux et on n'a même pas
eu à investir un sou tout s'est fait
bénévolement ou par des dons de divers
organismes ont ouvert la deuxième
garderie la garderie à 80 places
et puis la semaine prochaine on va
ouvrir maintenant nous regarderait 75
places mais j'insiste sur le fait que ce
n'est pas que les que la garderie qui
accueille les enfants
il ya un ensemble de services plus une
approche aux parents pour vraiment
toujours être une communauté autour des
enfants avec plein de partenaires ça
c'est les volets sont la vie collective
autour des enfants
j'aimerais maintenant vous parler de ce
qu'on essaie de faire avec les enfants
le vol du colibri c'est des valeurs
c'est des valeurs qu'on tente de
transmettre à travers un projet éducatif
qui est votée par l'assemblée générale
par la majorité de parents qui est
bonifié au fil des années dans ce projet
là on pense aussi toujours dans la même
vision du début que si on veut changer
le monde des habitudes ou des attitudes
les enfants peuvent apprendre très jeune
et qui vont rester profondément ancré
dans ce sont leurs mondes jeunes dont
notamment toute la question de l'accueil
de la diversité des personnes que je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on est toutes à
même de réaliser ça devient un défi très
important pour la suite du monde notre
hypothèse c'est aussi les enfants à
partir de bébés et tout jeunes
apprennent à vivre avec des personnes
qui ont des limitations physiques qui
ont des limitations intellectuelles les
personnes sont immigrantes ou encore des
personnes des premières nations pour
perdre et des gens qu'on peut rencontrer
loin ça devient dans leur coeur quelque
chose de normal différence qu'il ne voit
plus et ça risque de contribuer à un
monde un peu plus ouvert dans ce sens là
on accueille au vol du colibri des
adultes handicapés intellectuels et
physiques comme employé comme stagiaire
depuis les tout débuts
on accueille aussi des enfants issus de
l'immigration des enfants qui vivent eux
même avec des limitations puis des
enfants qui sont qui sont issus des
communautés cries je veux donner une
petite anecdote qui pour moi que je
trouve très très à 30 ans à attendre 100
au niveau des enfants on à la gare de
rennes enfin qui est assez fortement
handicapé quand il était à ces jeunes
parfois il était couché dans le local
puis il était fatigué pleurait beaucoup
ses amis dans son groupe avait dix-huit
mois à peu près dix huit à vingt mois il
avait vu l'éducatrice faire alors quand
le petit bonhomme se met à pleurer se
promener auto pl et le flatter le vent
pour pour le consoler 18 mois
aujourd'hui ces enfants adorent les
mêmes enfants qui sont avec lui tous
quatre ans ils vont l'aider à la
toilette ils vont l'aider à marcher mais
pour eux cet ami là c'est un ami comme
un autre avec des différences tout à
fait acceptable c'est la même chose on a
des petits enfants qui sont pas tous
blancs à la garderie heureusement et
on a un thème avec les enfants à
l'automne qui est justement pour le mois
des enfants on parle des enfants du
monde et à un moment donné une
éducatrice qui amènent des photos
d'enfants qui viennent d'afrique que
demande aux enfants ce que vous en
connaissez meilleur ami qui est de
couleur noire kate a vécu depuis des
années les enfants disent ben on en
connaît pas
pour eux c'est devenu normal et si ce
qu'on vise à ce niveau là dans notre
projet éducatif
un autre élément très important très
important aussi pour le sud du monde
c'est toute la question écologique on
essaie la garderie de donner des
habitudes aux enfants au niveau de
l'écologie donc apprendre à recycler
apprendre à composter faire un jardin le
planter puis éventuellement de récolter
parce que le des fois on oublie un petit
peu les chaleurs d'aller chercher les
légumes
ça va être l'étape de l'année prochaine
mais on apprend enfin donc s'approprier
la vie assez tôt autour de la guerre
dure on a la chance d'avoir plusieurs
parcs et un petit boisé les enfants vont
aussi dans le boisé
parce que une pédagogie écologique c'est
aussi une pédagogie de la nature que ça
devienne naturel pour les enfants d'être
dans un milieu naturel et on essaie
vraiment de leur faire vivre et où si ça
veut dire vive dans leur collectivité
donc elle est des activités organisées
rer a entre autres en transport en
commun
apprendre à connaître sa ville ça fait
aussi partie de l'écologie et on essaie
vraiment de rang des enfants conscients
de ça à ces jeunes toujours dans le but
d'intégrer aux dimensions de l'approché
des jeux éducatifs qui nous semble
important c'est de voir et et d'aller
dans des lieux sont artistes de les
initier à la culture est aussi de
développer leur créativité
c'est ce que tous les imaginaires et
tout ce qui est beau la dame est un peu
plus de ça on prétend que si on est très
jeune les enfants à développer les
petits chemins dans leur cerveau qui
vont leur permettre à eux de pouvoir
trouver des solutions dans le monde fort
complaisante éléments avoir ville à
vivre c'était d'en haut niveau au niveau
de leur apprentissage et on a aussi
évidemment j'en ai parlé beaucoup de
toute la question de la collaboration un
départ à la place des parents considérer
le parrain de l'enfant comme son expert
et que nous on travaille avec lui c'est
tout des aînés mac sont fort important
dans notre projet éducatif avec les
enfants du moins c'est ce qu'on tente de
faire et je dois vous dire que le paquet
personnes sont au vol du colibri qui
sont devenus une collectivité tant que
le changement à tous les jours et peu
importe l'âge
même à mon âge à moins allants là dessus
j'ai terminé avec la fin du livre que je
vous ai lu qui est une grande
inspiration pour le vol du colibri
imaginons un instant que les animaux
quelques-uns d'entre eux la majorité
tous face qui est en leur pouvoir
il se peut qu'il sache jamais ce leur
action sera ou non victorieuse les leur
contribution augmentera d'autant les
chances que toutes ses goûts réunis et
raison des flammes merci